لذلك قررنا أنا ومجموعة من الغرباء
في عائلتي استئجار شاحنة صغيرة مكونة من 15 راكبًا
والعودة ثماني ساعات إلى
تينيسي
[موسيقى]
كنت قد صعدت إلى شركة الطيران وكنت
مثل لماذا لا تستيقظون
مثل  حافلة كبيرة أو مثل شاحنة أو شيء من هذا
القبيل ، كانت هناك هذه الفتاة التي
سمعتني وأنا أقول ذلك إلى
المنضدة وكانت مثل هذه
فكرة جيدة حقًا وكانت تحب الصراخ
على الحشد مثل من يريد الذهاب
a van
um Robin وأنا هنا من أجل
أن يكون أبنائي أفضل ، اسمي Seth وقد
علقت هنا في أورلاندو بعد زيارة
بعض الأصدقاء ، مرحبًا ، أنا إيمي ، أنا من Cozumel
Mexico وأنا هنا أحاول الحصول على
صديقي الذي ينتقل إلى
المكسيك ، جامعة تينيسي ، أصبح
أجنبيًا بعد
ثلاث ساعات من رحلتنا المرتجلة ،
نحن الآن في جورجيا كما لو
كنا نقرأ التعليقات من
الناس وكنا نضحك
ولم نتوقع هذا نحن  فقط أصبحنا
مثل مليون مشاهدة بعد بضع
ساعات وكنا مثل ما هو g  حسنًا
، وبعد ذلك كان الأشخاص في التعليقات كما
لو أننا بحاجة إلى مزيد من التحديثات بعد الآن ،
لذا أثناء الرحلة واصلنا للتو
طرح أفكار مماثلة لما
سنفعله بعد ذلك ، وكانت إيمي كما لو
أننا جميعًا بحاجة فقط إلى الترقيم  نحن أنفسنا
لهذا حتى في كل مرة نتوقف فيها ،
نتأكد من أن الجميع في
الفرقة عندما نغادر ، لذلك أنا رقم واحد ،
أنا السائق ، لست متعبًا ، أنا رقم اثنين
، لا أعرف ماذا  هذا يعني أنني في
المركز الخامس والثالث والرابع لا أريد أن
أتحدث ،
إنها الساعة 8:30 صباحًا وقد
وصلنا إلى نوكسفيل وأنا متحمس
جدًا لأنني ما زلت قادرًا على القيام بجولة الكلية التي
أجريناها  إلى Knoxville ، نحن هنا
وقد لا أتأخر حتى عن العمل ، لذلك
هذا ما حددناه في الساعة 10 صباحًا
بسبب المجتمع الذي حصلوا عليه
لتحقيق الأشياء ، لا تدع الأشياء الصغيرة
تؤثر عليك وأنت تحقق أقصى استفادة
منها  أعتقد أن هذا درس ، على
الرغم من أنه حدث معنا ، فقد استخلصته
من تلك
[الموسيقى]